it's really i don't know it's i think
it's made to just break man's balls if
you allow me to say excuse my language
but
i don't believe there is such a thing as
feminism because
that dude like feminism these days
they're all complaining about men
getting more paid and this and that but
this is the only one percent of men that
they're actually doing good in life
they're getting good jobs and everything
but still like if you see the army
slash i don't know like cold miners
stuff like that like the all the hard
jobs they're man-made yeah i don't want
to do them yeah exactly
exactly so like yeah so like when you
say like when you see women they're more
like office jobs for women or like uh
nurses
like teachers stuff like that but like
you guys should be paid more for harder
jobs that makes sense well it is
happening now i know so technically we
get a little bit more money than you
guys do but
i think we're worth it do you think that
um
women should march the streets for male
only fans models and strippers that
don't get paid the same oh
why don't we do that we want equality
don't we
yeah why don't we march the street for
men yeah but see when you speak like
desires like sexual desire it's more
like everyone knows what men want to see
strippers and stuff like that no one
want to see naked men
no
but my point is like women will talk
about the pay gap all day when it comes
to like the one percent the ceos but but
they don't talk about the pay gap
between like male and female models
between male and female male only fans
models be male and female strippers i
feel like you're on outside yeah of
course
i have my sign
it's true yeah they're only talking
about
why they feel that we beating them on
while they feel that they're worse at
and they're not really saying the real
facts which is like they're only
comparing what the things that we do
good
and they're not good at and they're not
comparing the stuff that they're good at
and we're not good at well it's almost
like we only look for equality when it
benefits us but not when it but not when
it benefits like not when it's at the
cost of that exactly exactly thank you
and by the way if you if you check like
even
prison capacities like there's more men
than women
the amount of sentencing for the same
crime for the same crime exactly like if
if let's say just this building went on
fire
for some
some [ __ ] up reason i'll get out wait
for the women and the kids to go out
first and then i could save my life like
it's just
why do you think the feminists are
silent about these issues ah they're not
silenced they just you know the one i
see and one i don't see you know
they pretend to not see because
obviously that's what they want that's
what they want to talk about like oh
yeah women do this women do that and
they just want us to feel bad for them
but actually i think life is just good
for women let's be honest i think i'm at
an advantage as a woman
i think i'm i think as a young young
attractive women have an advantage over
young men yes i think so as well i think
so as well because like i don't know
women can call police over anything
and they'll get more aids than us what
do you think about the amber heard
johnny depp situation do you think that
kind of brings into the forefront the
the discrimination that feminism has
like had the last couple of years
because it was believe all women and
that that was the and now we're seeing
exactly and now we're seeing the
repercussions of that exactly that's
what i'm trying to say because like
women they get this this privilege that
they just need to say something and the
the law is supposed to to be on their
side supposed to believe them just like
it happened with amber and and johnny
depp like the guy got molested in
everything by his wife but just because
she's a woman first and second she's
crying and all of that people just start
believing her which is not and they gave
her an op-ed which is good they gave her
an op-ed with no proof which is crazy
yeah yeah she's still she still got out
of like two million but he got out of
like 17 million or something so but yeah
it's not fair it's not fair to be honest
well thank you so much i appreciate you
sitting down um do you have any do you
have any here nice to meet you do you
have any um social medias you want to
plug we have a hundred thousand
subscribers yeah yeah go ahead yeah well
i'll show you instagram youtube
oh yeah i'll follow you but you're not
super okay okay okay
okay
okay i didn't know some people plug
their social so thank you so much for
sitting down have a good one
yeah i think feminism is a hate group
because i think that it tears down men
and i i think they just advocate for
women and they advocate for women at the
cost of men okay so you think it's
detrimental to women nowadays
i think i think it's always been
detrimental
um okay and the reason being like they
push things like the pay gap when the
pay gap doesn't even exist
for women so they're they're actively
tearing down men to like build women up
and what do you think about like the
household situations
households so right now in the current
times a lot more women are independent
and then i've i've read somewhere that
they're saying that um
feminism is destroying actual the
household because it's making more women
be more independent i think there's
something about men becoming redundant
but i just like to gather information
yeah well i just think it lies to women
because it tells us to like chase a bag
and you know chase a career don't
prioritize family and then we end up
single childless and alone
and i think they do that at the cost of
men like most feminists i know they
don't they just they disdain that so
like what about this new movement happen
not hyper megan but like the um
what's it called again
what's the thing that we're
leveling up
leveling up yes
what do you mean by leveling up women
are now
we've been told to go and get men who
are more high high net worth high level
so they can be
treated have a soft life
treated better not chase the bag like
financially take care of the home what
do you think of that because that i've
read is that that's more against
feminism because i was reading something
that said feminism is detrimental to
women as well
so we need to go back to how it was
i think people should be free to choose
what they wanna i i feel like they
should be free to choose what they wanna
choose
but um i i think when you go when you
tell women to make a lot of money and
then only go after men that make more
money than you it leaves you as a side
piece because what what percentage of
men make uh six figures do you think not
a lot i think it's less than like
because the average in the uk is 36 000
or 36 something so how much men are
actually making lesser in like big
cities like london and stuff like that
yeah yeah so feminism is telling you to
like chase this career
when
like and then
you're gonna have a guy waiting for you
at the end of it but men aren't
attracted to that so can i ask you a
question so what would you say people
were like you're just being like you
have internalized misogyny
people do say that a lot um
and i would say that most people that
say that like have a victim mindset
where they just think the world is
against them and i think as a woman i'm
at an advantage rather than a
disadvantage that is very interesting
yeah no i love talking to you but i've
gotta go through with my sister oh no
that's okay thank you but no we're
sitting down
do you have any like any socials you
want to tag yeah
instagram yeah follow me
hot guys
hot guys hotties
it's glory love89 are you a feminist
do you know what yeah i think to be
honest i'm a meist
so what's most beneficial for me
that is what i am
so i'm not going to say i have not used
my own privileges to help me get certain
things yes i have okay
i've been the damsel in distress many
times but then i'm like no go women so
i'm a mist
thank you so much you're such a good
sport
yeah she was chill i liked her